schlechte nachrichten während das ozon
noch immer kleiner wird wird die
ozonschicht immer dünner das sind
ziemliche hiobsbotschaften war es also
ein irrglaube dass beim ozon alles
besser wird geht der erde
doch der schutz vor der gefährlichen uv
strahlung flöten klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
heute übrigens von der ju dem ewz
sommerfestival aus berlin
thema nummer 1 sehen den späten 80er
jahren das ozonloch mit hilfe des
montreal protokolls gelang es der
internationalen umweltpolitik die so
dringende kehrtwende einzuleiten und
zwar wurde die herstellung von fckw also
den langlebigen flur kohlenwasserstoffen
beschränkt vorher massiv eingesetzt als
kältemittel in kühlschränken und als
treibgas für sprühdosen und sie
zerstören das ozon in den hohen
schichten der erdatmosphäre massiv dabei
ist die ozonschicht extrem wichtig für
alle lebewesen auf der erde nämlich als
schutzschild gegen die lebensbedrohliche
uv-b-strahlung erstmals gibt es eine
gute nachricht seit dem montrealer
abkommen ist der verbrauch und auch die
produktion der schädlichen flow
kohlenwasserstoffe fckw um rund 90
prozent zurückgegangen kammer doch eine
schnelle erholung der ozonschicht sei
dennoch nicht zu erwarten sagt die
weltorganisation für meteorologie wmo
denn die schädlichen chemikalien bauen
sich extrem langsam ab eine zahl macht
allerdings hoffnung denn der ozongehalt
der atmosphäre hat sich seit dem jahr
2000 stabilisiert so studien welche
zahlen sind nun aussagekräftig und wie
steht es wirklich um das ozonloch erst
kürzlich ist dazu eine studie heraus
gekommen an denen wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen aus der schweiz und
zwar das physikalisch mythologischen auf
sat 1 in davos beteiligt waren und die
ergebnisse sind besorgniserregend denn
sie zeigen dass das ozonloch zwar immer
kleiner wird doch die ozonschicht über
den tropen und den mittleren breiten
dünnt weiter aus das fazit der forscher
und forscherinnen ist alarmierend denn
es zeigt dass die ozonschicht noch nie
so dünn gewesen ist wie derzeit aber
schauen wir doch mal detailliert auf die
einzelnen ergebnisse gut sieht es
bezüglich des ozon gehaltes in der
oberen stratosphäre aus nämlich in einer
höhe von 32 bis 48 kilometern
zudem zeigt sich auch dass sich das
ozonloch über der antarktis erholt hat
seitdem das montrealer abkommen
geschlossen wurde schlechte nachrichten
dagegen aus den unteren
atmosphärenschichten und zwar von der
meereshöhe bis zu durchschnittlich zwölf
kilometern
die aktuellen ergebnisse legen nahe dass
dort seit 1987 ozon verloren geht um
zwar kontinuierlich und unaufhaltsam
eine entwicklung die das forschungsteam
so nicht erwartet hat denn genau auf die
erholung dieser unteren schicht also von
null bis zwölf kilometern
da kommt es darauf an und macht den
erfolg in den oberen schichten in
gewisser weise wieder zunichte
dennoch passen diese horror ergebnisse
nicht zur vorherigen studien und
schätzungen nach denen sich das ozonloch
erholt ja sogar schließen soll doch
schaut man genauer hin sieht man auch
den grund dafür in vorherigen forschung
hat man sich vor allem das sogenannte
total ozon angeschaut damit ist
diejenige ozon menge gemeint die von der
erdoberfläche bis zur obersten grenze
der stratosphäre reicht hier wird der
verlust durch das wachstum kompensiert
ja und forschungsteams weltweit
versuchen schon seit längerer zeit die
atmosphäre und ihre mechanismen zu
verstehen doch hierbei spielen einfach
zu viele faktoren eine rolle
beispielsweise der luftaustausch
zwischen den unterschiedlichen
atmosphärenschichten genauso wichtig
aber ist es die ursachen zu finden
die hinter dem enorm ozonabbau steckt
möglicherweise liegt es an den
sogenannten very short lift substances
vsl es also kurzlebigen halogen
verbindung die aus industriellen
prozessen stammt denn auch sie gelangen
in die stratosphäre und schädigen dort
die ozonschicht das hatte eine studie
eines münchner forschungsteams gezeigt
aber auch der klimawandel hat wohl
auswirkungen auf das ozon denn die
erderwärmung könnte zu einer veränderten
luftverteilung in der stratosphäre
führen und auch die schädlichen fckw
sind noch längst nicht geschichte alte
kühlgeräte werden noch längst nicht auf
der ganzen welt ordnungsgemäß recycelt
das fckw wird dort einfach nicht
eingesammelt das forschungsteam der
aktuellen studie allerdings äußerte die
vermutung dass irgendwo heimlich noch
größere mengen an fckw produziert werden
durch die analyse verschiedener
messmethoden schließen sie darauf dass
die gestiegenen emissionen in
südostasien lokalisiert werden können
doch das ist nur eine vage vermutung und
keinesfalls bewiesen
am ende jedenfalls hat die ausdünnung
des ozons fatale folgen für uns alle
denn es gibt immer weniger ozon das uns
vor der uv-strahlung schützen kann so
steigt das hautkrebsrisiko bei menschen
industrie politik und wissenschaft sind
also in sachen ozon noch mindestens
genauso gefragt und gefordert nach
lösungen zu suchen wie eh und je ja und
wenn ihr keine videos dazu zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
hättet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er
die kaputte a box hier auf youtube und
verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp
erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video und zwar
täglich und garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal kriegs um social media
abonnieren
das gibt geht hier da gibt es das
neueste aus der social media welt also
einfach hier draufklicken aber nicht die
genau glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
klimawandel weltweites wetterchaos hat
begonnen bis dann bleibt